je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'identité
heureuse quand il ya 6 millions de
chômeurs et le plein emploi en allemagne
je pense qu'il a pas d'identité heureuse
quand il ya des jeunes français nés en
france
éduqué en france qui sont moins bien
intégré que leurs grands parents qui eux
mêmes n'étaient pas nés en france et je
pense qu a pas d'identité heureuse quand
il ya un islam politique provoquant qui
veut imposer un changement du mode de
vie français
voilà vous avez croisé de ces deux
débats de débaptiser un gilet à la super
soldat et c'est là que les français
m'ont parfaitement compris ils savent
très bien que je mesure bien que la
france ne nage pas dans le bonheur
on en a parlé tout au long de ces
émissions en revanche je pense ou le
rôle d'un chef d'état c'est de fixer un
cap et sur quatre ce doit être à la
réconciliation des français
ça doit être une france qui retrouve le
bonheur de vivre ensemble c'est le thème
que j'ai développé pendant toute ma
campagne et je crois que les français
l'ont bien compris